i would say the perfect word to describe
pete is genuine pete davidson is making
a good impression on kim kardashian's
kids it's really lit and fun and crazy
looks like the keyt romance is heating
up by the day a source tells e.t kim and
pete have had a strong connection since
day one and it's only getting stronger
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing the skim's
founder may be smitten now but admits
she had her initial reservations about
pete especially when it came to
introducing him to her kids who she
shares with kanye west north saint
chicago and psalm i text him i wasn't
even thinking like oh my god i'm going
to be in a relationship with him i was
just thinking like
heard about this bde need to get out
there like i need to just like
jump start my
i was just basically dtf
well now that kim has passed the simply
dtf stage our e.t source says the mom of
four was just being cautious about
bringing pete around her kids when they
started dating because she wasn't sure
the relationship was serious now quote
the kids and pete get along very well
and kim seeing him be so great with them
only made her fall in love with pete
moore pete is has got to be literally
the best human being i've ever met like
the best heart but pete and kim's road
to a blended family wasn't smooth the
introduction came with its challenges
amid kim's divorce from kanye you just
gotta roll with it we've learned yay
made it clear he wasn't on board with
the kids meeting the snl alum and
thankfully kim's family stepped in with
support according to our source the
reality star's family played a big part
in helping kim navigate the situation
i definitely noticed that kim is happier
i think that she's so much nicer now
thank you pete i'm so into this new kim
the kardashian jenner crew seemed to not
get enough of their love for pete when
e.t sat down with the family ahead of
the hulu show's premiere
what do you all love about pete i love
that he's kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love the chemistry that kim and
him have together it's really sweet i
thought you said the chemistry i'm just
like okay chemistry chemistry
[Music]
you